("Bon-Vacance" by AudioNetwork)
- Stupid.
- Hey, what's up?
- I hate my new boss.
- You hate all of your bosses.
- No, this guy is the fucking worst.
I have to wear this stupid...
- Jabot.
- What?
- Well it's called a jabot.
- It's stupid and the freaking
night shift is killing me.
- Well hey, you start at the
bottom with the night shift
and you work your way up the day shift.
- I don't think there is a day shift.
This guy is a weirdo, okay.
His skin is all pale and chalky.
He looks like a crispy powdered donut.
- Ew.
- I know, I don't think he gets out much.
He's like 4,000 years old.
- Stop complaining 'cause I would do
anything for a job right now.
- Not this guy, I mean,
I can handle a micro-manager but it's like
every time I get up, he's
just been standing there
the whole time, breathing down my neck,
like, (heaving breathing)
and then there's this
awful moth ball smell.
I don't know if it's just
when he's in bat form
or he's standing right
behind me, isn't he?
(suspenseful music)
- Don't worry, we've got
the good health insurance.
- Whatever, as long as
I can log these hours.
- You know, some people
would kill to work from home.
- Are you A positive?
You go great with Malibu.
("Bon-vacance" by AudioNetwork)
- Oh and thanks for the
Coppertone SPF a billion.
- Anything to keep my boss alive.
- I am, I am alive.